Oh interesting because i honest to a
whorl IQ were suicidal no I've never
felt suicidal ever my dear I've been
very sad like very deep anything this
depression right like i freshen before
but i never thought about killing myself
because i was like man you two dopes
what's the world in dude i was it's so
interesting to be so far on the other
side now but I was I was what I would
call passively suicidal
we're like literally every day every
[ __ ] day I wanted to die but like I
didn't have the balls to like actually
do it not hurt I just yeah but like if
it happened to me I genuinely believed
that I would have been like happy and I
was I was so suit I was so suicidal that
I got I got so angry and I remember
being pissed off at somebody that
volunteered for a suicide prevention
thing because when I had to go through
that it their method of keeping you on
this earth is guilt tripping you it's
telling you that this person's gonna
miss you how could you do that to this
person and I was that made me so angry I
don't know if anyone else has ever been
had to go through some kind of suicide
prevention they they basically their
tactic is well let's just keep them here
for now and then we'll get them help but
for somebody that has the weight of the
world on their chest with no it's not
it's not what they need at all and it
would piss me off so much because I was
like you are not me you are not going
through this you are not going through
this pain it is selfish for you to want
to keep me here
when I don't want to be here and I
wanted so [ __ ] bad I wanted so badly
to kill myself I really did like I just
wanted to die but I David when I was
purchasing a car I was looking up safest
vehicles 20:19 are you trying to you
like precious cargo
yes absolutely a complete 180
i I built this life for myself that like
and in it and you know it started with
Smosh like I got I feel like I got so
lucky to get pulled into that and I
cannot imagine I can't I can't
go back to that place that I was oh yeah
I had like this episode where we're
talking about Sue and I brought a guest
on who attempted to kill herself
and the reason why is because I can't
relate to it so I can't really talk
about it right yeah I mean like I don't
know what that feels like Romney are now
obscene I read you my diary entries
David you know I'm beyond you I give you
all like dark stickers on instant the
closer I got to killing myself with
bacon that's about it I'm pretty [ __ ]
good dude
like I think like the reason why I
stayed alive was just to piss people off
it's like I'm gonna kill myself I'm
alive who you gonna hate like I gotta
stay alive just to annoy you like why
the [ __ ] do you get to live and be happy
[ __ ] that what happened she okay so she
was a cancer survivors my cancer class
and then you even after she survived
cancer twice she had a really good she
her name is Kat sweets
great bakery self business person blows
up still didn't feel like it was worth
living because of all the [ __ ] that
she's going through she had a
miscarriage she lost her kid too as well
Wow and then she decides to try to kill
herself and it luckily it didn't work
out yeah and you know I think like it's
it's hard because like when you're in
these like dark moments the the tool
that a lot of people don't have the form
oh and I'm gathering from hearing all
these stories is that pain doesn't feel
temporary yeah suicide that is exactly
what it is I I I don't really give a lot
of people advice on this because I
because my world took like a full 180
after I joined Smosh and moved out to LA
shoutouts to Smosh and [ __ ] and that's
not an opportunity that a lot of people
get so it's like my situation isn't that
relatable but what ended up happening
was I got plucked out of this depression
and just given a new chance yeah and so
then I started looking okay well
I'm out here like how do I make this
work how do I do this so the only thing
lights help people is when you are
severely depressed when you're feeling
suicidal you need to find a mentor you
need I'm not even a mentor maybe like a
somebody to look up to what the [ __ ] is
that call a role model yeah you need a
role model that lives the life that you
want to live because you need to be able
to visualize yourself somewhere other
than where you are and whether it be it
sounds wack but creating a vision board
to just find that role model to envision
try to envision that life that you want
you you need that because you're right
it's like it feels like this there's no
way out of this pain and the only way
out of this pain is to end everything
and everything is temporary and on top
of that when you look at these people
who you want to be like and you see
sometimes that it doesn't feel like it's
attainable a lot of people don't share
all the scars and the wars that they
went through just to get to who they are
as a person now and so you're trying to
you're trying to fast forward these
steps to see like I want what they have
without going everything that they went
through yeah they just had like the the
mental fortitude to get through it right
so if you see this what are you like
even for me if you look at me as a hero
Wow I feel for you guys thank you like
well you know like they're like oh how
do you do this like how did you start
doing stand-up to going into film and
doing all this other stuff it's like
well you weren't there for me when I got
booed off a stage you weren't there for
me when you know like little friends
have laughed saying that I couldn't
become a stand-up you were there for me
when I've had like teachers tell me that
I wasn't gonna be anything like these
are stuff that built me up as a human
now it was very hard to get through that
[ __ ] but at the same time it's like
there's no way that I would have been
Who I am now without that [ __ ] yeah cuz
I needed I needed to hear those type of
things it's just like for me at the time
and the tool that you don't have once
again is the fact that you thought you
think that when you go through that that
this is gonna be the rest of your life
and I never thought that it was like
this is temporary I have to get over
this [ __ ] I've talked about my anxiety
like how I used to this probably the
third time I mentioned it but I want to
bring it up again because I didn't I
couldn't order food at a fast-food
restaurant cuz I couldn't talk to people
because I had such anxiety issues
like oh god the rest I couldn't order
food a restaurant a fast food restaurant
I couldn't make eye contact with people
I can do any of this [ __ ] do we stand it
you know so come on look if if somebody
like me can do it I think that you can't
- yeah have to accept the [ __ ]
beating that you're gonna get to get to
that that ass-whooping that you're gonna
get is you just have to accept it
because it's going to happen there are
people out there right now that are
[ __ ] trash and even they have a
they're successful in their [ __ ] and
yeah in something they're resilient or
or you know those that ask beating you
have that that as beating that
everyone's had that pain it's not just
in unfortunate instance it's not just
life [ __ ] on you it's a lesson every
single thing is a lesson and with each
instance of pain I don't think people
even realized how much stronger they're
getting like every day like I I I would
probably I would relive a lot of this
[ __ ] that's happened to me just like
just to become stronger like again like
I would I wouldn't if I could go back in
my life I wouldn't change anything there
is no situation that was so bad that I
was like oh I could do without that [ __ ]
no dude I learned something from that
and no matter how bad it was it made the
other bumps in the road less scary
because like like a-- and i use this as
an example for losing my job out of
nowhere like i career-wise I can conquer
anything I'm not afraid of anything like
in that field I'm really not unless like
somebody wants to like [ __ ] sue me
please don't sue me
but I mean for the most part like that
that pain was a huge lesson and it was
like a huge elevator because now the
little things I'm not scared of and also
lessened my anxiety so much because when
you conquer it you're not constantly
thinking about it anymore because you
know when it comes up you got this
whereas when I was at my job when I
first moved out here to LA every single
day I was like what's gonna happen if I
get fired
what if somebody hates me and I get
fired what the audience hates mean I get
fired what if I [ __ ] something up and I
get fired what if I get fired what if I
get fired and then it was like okay now
you lost the job and then I conquered it
and then like it's not a fear of mining
yeah yeah I mean that's
it's just like this oh god I really not
that I say I wish like I tried to commit
suicide but it's like one of those
things it's like damn this is something
that I really can't relate to yeah like
it's hard and I and I even relate this
back to something small so you know when
mr. so mr. Rogers passed away right I I
wasn't born here so I had to learn how
to speak English to every other facet
that wasn't my parents right it was
usually television and school and
whatever so um one of the shows that I
used to really really really really
[ __ ] love was mr. Rogers neighborhood
as a little kid when mr. Rogers died I
[ __ ] cried and I didn't know why
because I didn't really think much about
him right I was like mr. Rogers passed
away and I remember I was in my Isuzu
Trooper which was one of my first cars
ever and I was driving and it was like
from the Men's Wearhouse and I was
driving back to back home and I remember
this day because it hit me so hard when
he died I heard it on the radio and I
started bawling my [ __ ] eyes out no
and I don't remember I was sitting there
and I was thinking like how the [ __ ]
were you crying
I guess mr. Rogers like you know I mean
like do you even remember a single
episode that you saw from mr. Rogers at
all and I started to realize later on
when I was watching his show and I
watched this little clip of him